[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام اليس حريا
بالعرب والمسلمين ان يقفوا الى جانب تركيا
للتصدي للهجمه الفارسيه الشيعيه على
العربي والاتراك يتساءل كاتب
عربي اليست المقارنه بين الدورين التركي
والايراني في المنطقه
كالمقق
والثرى هل جلبت ايران للبلدان العربيه
التي تدخلت فيها غير الخراب
والدمار الم تهجر ملايين السوريين
والعراقيين بينما استقبلت تركيا ملايين
اللاجئين الم تحول ايران العراق الى افشل
دوله في العالم الم يتحول لبنان بعد ان
سيطرت عليه ايران من سويسرا الشرق الى
اكبر مزبله في الشرق
الاوسط لكن في المقابل الا تمتلك تركيا
ايضا مشروعها العثماني الجديد للهيمنه على
المنطقه لماذا حلال على الاتراك وحرام على
الايرانيين طالما ان المنطقه العربيه
تحولت الى فراغ كبير لابد ان يملاه
الاخرون اليست المطامع التركيه واضحه
المعالم في شمال سوريا والعراق الم تسلم
تركيا حلب ومعها المعارضه السوريه
للايرانيين والروس من اجل مصالحها لماذا
نلوم ايران على العبث بالمنطقه وتشييعها
اذا كانت تركيا ايضا عبثت بما فيه الكفايه
بسوريا وغيرها اسئله اطرحها على الدكتور
رائد المصري استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه وعلى الكاتب التركي
محمد زاهد جول نبدا نقاش بعد
الفاصل
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم في برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس دكتور
رائد لو بدات معك اجرينا على ضوء
المناوشات الاعلاميه الاخيره بين ايران
وتركيا وخاصه بعد تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
التركي عندما انت اتهم ايران بانها تحاول
تشييع دول المنطقه اجرينا استفتاء على
تويتر موقع تويتر مفتوح للجميع فيما لو
حصل اي صراع بين الايرانيين
والاتراك من
تؤيد كانت النتيجه ان
96% من المصوتين يعني وانت تعلم تويتر ليس
تابعا لاحد يؤيدون تركيا ويعارضون كل
المواقف الايرانيه الا تعتقد ان ايران
تخوض معركه خاسره وتضيع جهودها في منطقه
ترفضها بالكامل تمام يعني اولا تاسيسا على
حلقتك والمقدمه اللي تفضلت فيها لحتى
ننطلق عربيا من بحكم هذه العلاقه التركيه
الايرانيه اذا بدنا ننطلق عربيا ناسس
عليها شيء وان نتعاطى علاقات ايرانيه
تركيا شيء م صحيح لا نحن عربيا طب عربيا
ممتاز كثير وبتكون الحلقه هيك اثمن لا شك
طيب اولا ما فينا نحن نبني على المواقع
الافتراضيه اي مزاج في العالم بهذا يعني
غير مثبت عمليا لا نحن ولا الاوروبيين
ثانيا اذا بدنا نتحدث نحن على الحضور كعرب
بالنسبه للدور الايراني او للدور التركي
الدور التركي كان اكثر من مضر وقاتل
للمنطقه العربيه مضر وقاتل طبعا الى هذا
الحد رح اقول لك ليش لانه بدايه لانه جوهر
الصراع الحقيقي الذي يحكم منطقتنا كعرب
وكمس لمين هو الصراع مع الكيان الصهيوني
الذي يغتصب الارض تركيا تمتلك علاقات جيده
واستراتيجيه مع الكيان الصهيوني ا وهذا
بدوره يعطل كل
مفاهيم الصراع الموجوده في المنطقه او
المحاوله البناء على اسس سلام في هذه
المنطقه ا من هنا نجد ان الدور الايراني
هو دور مكمل هو داعم للمقاومه محتضن
للقضيه الفلسطينيه انا علينا كعرب ان ناخذ
من قوه ايران ما يدفع بنا وما يقوينا
باتجاه العدو الاستعماري الصهيوني ان هذا
هو الصراع الحقيقي اذا بدنا نتحدث كعرب
وكمن عربيه تطالها كل شضايا القوى
الاستعماريه في المنطقه سواء تركيا او
الحلف الاطلسي او اسرائيل او غير ذلك من
هنا نبدا لذلك انا اعتبر ان يعني انت تضع
تركيا الى جانب اسرائيل في في في معادا
العرب طبعا هي تمتلك طبعا هي هي ال جانب
اسرائيل وتم وتحتل قطع ارض عربيه يعني
تحتل اراضي عربيه تاريخيا وبالتالي في فرق
كبير ما بين
ان ايران تمتلك او تريد ان تحقق مصالحها
في المنطقه وهذا امر مشروع في العلاقات
الدوليه وما بين تركيا التي لديها احلام
عثمانيه تاريخيه بيضع ي بوضع يدها على
المنطقه وشفنا لديها احلام عثمانيه طبعا
قدي وتاريخيه وبعدها لحد هلا عم بتحاول
احيائها من جديد في سوريا احيتها في
العراق احيتها و بسوريا بابشع يعني صورها
اذا بدك ونتحدث خلال الحلقه يعني هذا هو
الواقع طيب كيف كيف بدنا نتعاطى نحن مع
الدوري الايراني لا الدور الايراني كان
دور ايجابي بالنسبه داعم لقوى المقاومه
على الاقل بوجه المشروع الامريكي
الاستعماري وربيبتها اسرائيل التي زرعت
واقتلعت شعب فلسطين وشردت من من اراضيه
هذه هي الحقيقه ا جميل جدا كيف ترد يا
سيدي تحت مسمى الحرب على الارهاب وتحت
مسمى دعم المقاومه
اسرا يعني ايران تعبث في المنطقه بشكل
واضح وصريح وتقوم بتد ارفع شعار القدس
وافعل ما تشاء تماما تدمر المنطقه تهجر
المنطقه تستبيح المنطقه وهي ربما كدور في
الوقت الراهن كعمل على الارض استطيع ان
اقول انها قوه تدميريه اكثر بكثير من
اسرائيل فمن قتلتهم ايران منذ بدايه
الثوره ما يسمى بالثوره الايرانيه سنه ال
79 حتى هذه اللحظه من العرب والمسلمين في
ارجاء المعموره تتجاوز الارب ملايين بمعنى
ان اسرائيل لم تقم لم تقم بتدمير وقتل
المسلمين وتهجيرهم كما فعلته كما فعلته
ايران والمشروع الايراني في الم ثم تاتي
ايران وتقول نحن ندافع عن العرب ونهاجم
اسرائيل تماما يعني تاريخيا بامكاننا ان
نقول يعني هذا المشروع الفارسي حقيقه الذي
تقوده ايران اليوم اذا استطعنا ان نقول
انها اين موقفها في اي محفل اسلامي ما هي
الفتو الاسلاميه التي قامت بها ما هي
المساهمه التي قامت بها ايران
كحضارة في التعاون ما بين الاوروبيين ضد
الدوله العثمانيه وظهور الاتراك حتى في
المسرح التاريخي لم يكن الا في التكامل مع
العنصر العربي انا فقط انقل من هنا ما
يقوله المؤرخ ابن خلدون الذي يعتبر مقبولا
لدى الجميع يقول بالحلف الواحد اذ بينما
كانت الخلافه الاسلاميه قد ضعفت وفسد
امرها ولم تعد قادره صد اعدائها جلب الله
لها بحكمته وحسن تدبيره واحسان
حكاما وحماه جددا من قبائل الترك العديده
العظيمه حتى ينفث فيها الروح في جسم
الاسلام الايل للفناء ويعيد الى المسلمين
وحدتهم يعني هذا نص واحد يؤكد على الرؤيه
التاريخيه على الاقل للاتراك المسلمين
الذين دخلوا في تعاون وثيق وحموا الدوله
العباسيه ايام السلاجقه وحكموا وحموا بيضه
الاسلام في ايام الدوله العثمانيه وعندما
ننظر حتى في التاريخ المعاصر وحتى نتحدث
اليوم عن الواقع المعاصر نجد ان المشروع
التركي يقوم على التعامل والتكاتف مع
الشعوب العربيه ومع الدول العربيه ليس لا
عثمن ولا تمدد ولا استغلال ولا هم يحزنون
المشروع تماما كما نشاهده اليوم في جرابلس
اقل من 100 يوم في درع الفرات او قرابه ال
100 يوم في عمليات درع الفرات اكثر من
40,000 سوري مهجر الان يستوطنون في جرابلس
وما حولها خدمات اجتماعيه خدمات مدارس
خدمات صحيه حدائق الان موجوده في جرابلس
وهي خدمات لم يكن تتوافر عليها سوريا قبل
عمليه درع الكره بينما تركيا ستنسحب قريبا
من هذه المنطقه بعد ان يكون هناك امن
واستقرار في هذه المنطقه بينما ايران ماذا
تفعل يا سيدي كما قلت لك تدمير تهجير قتل
سياسه طائفيه تقوم على بشكل مباشر على
استخدام الطائفه وعلى استخدام الخطاب
المذهبي من اجل الخداع من اجل التوسع ومن
اجل القتال يعني تحت مسمى الحرب على
الارهاب هي تقتل وتحت مسمى الحرب على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي تقوم
بالتنسيق قاسم سليماني اليوم وفي العام
الماضي كان يقوم بالتنسيق المباشر على
الارض تحت مسمى الحرب على الارهاب مع
الطائرات الامريكيه المقاتله في العراق
كلنا شهدنا الكثير من التدمير الذي حصل في
العراق وهو في التنسيق الايراني الامريكي
المباشر اتنكر بشكل مباشر ان ان ايران
والخميني تحديدا والخميني تحديدا اتنكر ان
الخميني
تحديدا تعاون بشكل مباشر مع دوله الكيان
الاسرائيلي الذي سميته واشترى منها
الاسلحه التي تجاوز اسعارها وصفقاته
المليار دولار في ذلك الوقت من اجل مقاتله
صدام حسين من اجل مقاتله بلد عربيم يكن
هناك تعاون يا سيدي انا فقط جمله واحده
باختصار شديد ليس كلام هذا كلام رئيس
الرئيس الايراني الاسبق حسين بني الصدر
يقول بشكل واضح وصريح في احد المقابلات
يقول فيها ان ايران يا سيدي انما هي تدعي
وتزعم انها عدوه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
وتقول ايران تمارس سياستين احدهما في
الظاهر الصراع مع امريكا والغرب وفي
الخفاء التعاون هذا ليس كلامي وان انما
كلام الرئيس الايراني ابو الحسن بني الصدر
الذي هرب من طغيان الخميني الى فرنسا منذ
عاما ان اقول ان هناك تعاون حقيقي لتدمير
المنطقه تعاون حقيقي لد نستشهد في هذا
اللي عم بتقوله معلش يعني هذا ما يعني غير
يعني ورقه غير قابله للنقاش ان تتحدث مع
واحد هربان من النظام ويتحدث بالضال ما
بقدر يعني انا بعدين انت تحدثت عن يعني
ابن خلدون ومقولته التاريخيه وكذا اللي
بناها يعني وانت من فمك ادينك اللي بناها
على المنطق القبلي والمنطق الحكم القائم
على العائله وهذا منطق الدوله التركيه
يعني تاريخيا طيب تفضل تفضل تفضل طيب بس
انا بس خلينا ناخذها طيب دكتور خلينا نحن
كي لا نذهب بعيدا لو ذكرت اسم ايران في اي
بلد في العالم الان اذهب الى اي بلد في
العالم في الشرق في الغرب في الشمال في
الجنوب اسال الناس في الشوارع في اي مكان
في العالم ماذا يعني لكم اسم ايران
سيقولون لك فورا ايران الارهاب ايران
القتل ايران الاجرام ايران التطبير ايران
كذا لو ذكرت اسم تركيا في
العالم العالم سيقول شيئا اخر خلينا نكون
واقعيين يعني تركيا تركيا تعني الحضاره
تركيا ماذا صدرت ايران للعالم العربي او
للعالم على مدى العقود الماضيه العرا صدرت
التطبير والدماء انا بس بدي اسالك سؤال بس
مشان ننطلق منها طيب هل تدخلت ايران في اي
بلد في الع العالم العربي الا وكانت
النتيجه دمارا وخرابا العراق احتلت العراق
فاصبح العراق افشل دوله في العالم احتلت
لبنان تحول لبنان الذي كان يسمى سويسرا
الشرق الى اكبر مزبله في الشرق الاوسط
احتلت سوريا سوريا انت عم تعمل يا دكتور
انت عم تعمل استطراد
باسئلتي ومقدمات لبنان ليس بلد زباله
لبنان هزم الكيان الصهيوني وهو لديه
مقاومه يعتز فيها كل العرب
كل العرب يعتزون بهذه المقاومه التي حررت
جنوب لبنان وتحرر اراضي وتدعس راس
الصهيوني المتعامل مع المشروع الامريكي
التركي الاطلسي في المنطقه هذا اولا ثانيا
منو اللي قال انه انا يعني لست هنا الناطق
بلسان الحكومه الايرانيه انا عم بتحدث
واقع دولي في المنطقه كيف ننظر اليه وكيف
يمكن ان نستفيد منه كعرب بالنسبه لقضيتنا
اما ان ننعت هي يكفي انها كانت داعمه لقوى
المقاومه من دمر العراق هو العرب وهم
العرب الذين تح حالفوا مع امريكا واحتلوها
عام 2003 وضربوها عام 1990 وغير ذلك من
حروب كيف يعني ليش بدنا نضلل بالتاريخ
هناك حقائق واضحه
ودامغة معك ا لماذا هذه الشيعيه لم تكن
موجوده منذ عام
1923 عندما بنوا التحالف بين الشاه شاه
وبين اتاتورك لماذا لم تكن موجوده اثناء
قيام حلف بغداد بوجه عبد الناصر ما بين
بون جوريون وما
بين رئيس الحكومه التركيه لماذا لم تكن
هناك حاله مذهبيه عندما كانت العلاقات
وثيقه وموثقه ما بين ايران وتركيا قبل
قيام الثوره الم تكن شيعي
الم تكن وقتها شيعيه الم تكن تتحدث
بالمذهب لماذا تصاعد اليوم وبدات تتحدثون
عن ان ايران هي هي تصدر هي تصدر المنطق
الشيعيه ليش تسعير اليوم هذا التسع الم
لان هي وقفت بوجه المشروع الامريكي
والمشروع
الاست خليني اسالك سؤال دكتور بس مشان
يعني نوضحها للناس طيب انا كعربي كيف اصدق
ان ايران تريد تحرير فلسطين او تتحر القدس
اذا كانت تحتل العراق وسوريا واليمن
ولبنان وتحاول ان تحتل البحرين وتتمدد في
الخليج شو هالكذب الكبيره يا رجل هذه
الكذبه الكبيره من يقتل السنه السوريين
ومن يقتل السنه العراقيين ومن يقتل السنه
اللبنانيين ومن يقتل السنه اليمنيين لا
يمكن ان يرحم السنه الفلسطينيين حاجتنا
كذب يا زلمه حاجتنا كذب يا دكتور هذا
تاريخ هذا
هي الذي حققته
انها طيب تركيا تحتل سوريا ولا لا احتلت
لواء اسكندرون ولا لا احتلت بعشيقه ولا لا
في العراق تركيا هل تدين هل هل هل تدين
احتلال تركيا للواء اسكندرون منذ عام 1938
تفضل هي ارض
عربيهه سوريه لواء اسكندرون بناء على
تقسيم سيسبيكو اذا كان هذا هو المرجع نعم
بامكاننا الحديث عن لا لا لا ليس وثائق
تاريخيه
طيب يعني انت تعترف طيب انت تعترف اذا
باحتلال ايران للعراق وسوريا واليمن
ولبنان
و ما في احت انا عم بحكي احتلال
مباشر د يا دكتور من الذي يدير العراق انا
بدي ارجع اسالك السؤال بالله جاني 100 مره
يقولون الايران التي تقتل سنه سوريا وسنه
العراق وسنه لبنان وسنه اليمن كيف تشفق
على سنه فلسطين شو هالكذب الكبيره بعدين
واحد قال ساخرا واحد قال ساخرا بس خليني
اكم لك اياه واحد قال ساخرا قال نحن نعلم
نعلم لماذا ايران تريد ان تحرر فلسطين
يبدو ما كفتها العراق ولا سوريا ولا اليمن
ولا لبنان ولا كل المنطقه ب بد تحتل
فلسطين عر هي العواصم ها لا نحن اذا بدنا
نتحدث انا فيني اقول لك هلا انت قتلت
مليون او العراق او تركيا قتلت مليونين
يعني ما فينا نتحدث نحن انه هي تد انا عم
بحكي عن واقع استراتيجي امتلكته تركيا
واستخدمته
من ت واحتلت جز من الاراضي العراقيه وهي
اراضي عربيه احتلال مباشر بجيش وعسكر
ودبابات صح ولا م صح الحقي جميل جدا طيب
انا بسالك بالاتجاه الاخر الرجل يوجهلك
بقوللك لماذا حلال على تركيا وحرام على
ايران الان تركيا موجوده في شمال سوريا ام
غير
موجوده تركيا موجوده في اقسام من في اجزاء
من العراق او غير موجوده فاذا نحن يعني
العرب الان في واقع الامر هم لا يواجهون
صديقا مقابل عدو يواجهون قوه خارجيه تتمثل
في الايرانيين وحتى الاتراك يريدون
الهيمنه على المنطقه يعني الصراع الصراع
او هيمنوا الصراع بين قوى تتقاتل علينا
باختصار شديد كيف ترد على صار شديد لواء
اسكندرون اذا كانت محتله لنفترض ذلك جدلا
فريسك بشار الاسد تنازل عنها بشكل ارجوك
يعني الرئيس بشار الاسد الذي يم الرس بشار
الاس هو رئيس سوريا تنازل عنها بشكل مباشر
عبر توقيع ومذكرات رسميه وانتهى الموضوع
فهذا الموضوع خلونا اه على جنب اما
الموضوع
الان هو انتهى هو حيه ولا حتى الرئيس ولا
حتى اي قوه في العالم تستطيع ان تلغي ارض
وتضمها الى الى
مجتمعين وغيرها من الاتفاقيات اللي حصلت
بين سوريا وتركيا واتفاقيه اضن كلها تثبت
لا لا جاوبني جابني بالسه لواقع جابني على
الواقع الان انتم تقولون انه ايران تحتل
سوريا وتحتل اليمن وتحتل كذا وانتم تحتل
وانتم تسيطرون انتم تحاولون ان تتمدد هكذا
يقولون كيف تر تمام بشكل واضح وجود تركيا
وجود عارض في الشمال السوري لن لن تبقى
طويلا في هذه المنطقه على الاطلاق وجودها
بسبب ضرورات الامن القومي بسبب الهجمات
التي جاءت على تركيا من تنظيمات متعدده
مختلفه جزء كبير منها مدعوم من ايران
وبالتالي تركيا في الوقت الراهن دخلت في
هدف محدد وهداف معلنه مرحليه واليوم من
يدير جرابلس ليس الجيش التركي وليس الجهات
التركيه التي من تدير جرابلس هناك مجلس
محلي من السوريين من اهالي هذه المنطقه هم
من يديرون هذه المنطقه وستبقى كذلك والباب
كذلك ومدينه الباب التي
بدات بدات تركيا اعاده اعمارها منذ ان
اعلن عن تحريرها بشكل كامل اليوم ايضا سي
يديرها ويديرها عمليا اصحابها الاصليون
واصحاب ووا يعودون اليها اكثر من 40,000
يا دكتور انا عندما اخذت الارقام الرسميه
من الحكومه التركيه خاصه من مدينه بلديه
غازي عنتاب التي تشرف على اعاده الاعمار
في هذه المنطقه قالوا ان اكثر من 40,000
حتى هذه اللحظه عادوا الرقم ضخم جدا رغم
انا ما كنت متخيل انه هذا بهذا الحجم
الكبير وبالتالي تركيا حقيقه حسب ما سمعت
من كل المسؤولين اتراك وكل التصريحات
واضحه في هذا السياق لا يريدون شبر ارض من
سوريا وانما سيعودون وبالنسبه ل بعشيقه
وبالنسبه ل بعشيقه خليني اجاوب عليها
بعشيقه قاعده
عسكريه جاءت بالتوافق مع الحكومه حتى في
بغداد هم ينكرون هذا الامر لكن يبدو ان
العلاقات والزيارات التي تبادلت تم
التفاهم عليها وسيكون هناك انسحاب من
بعشيقه في غضون شهرين اثنين فقط لا اكثر
وبالتالي لا يمكننا الحديث عن هيمنه
وسيطره او اطماع تركيا بينما ايران سيدي
يعني كما قال حيدر مصلحي وزير الاستخبارات
الايراني وكما تفضلت انهم يسيطرون في
الوقت الراهن على عواص اربع عواصم عربيه
حسن زم قال لك انه طريق القدس يمر من حلب
فبالتالي هم انحرفوا بشكل واضح وصريح عن
الطريق واذا كنا نتحدث عن دعم المقاومه
بشكل عام ماذا فعلت ايران ماذا فعل حسن
زميره بشكل واضح وصريح في حرب غزه الاخيره
هل هل قاموا بدعم بدعم الصمود
الاسطوري حزب الله يا سيدي ماذا فعلت في
حرب غز الاخيره والتي قبلها هل وقفوا مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه هل وقفوا مع اهل
فلسطين هل وقفوا مع اهل غزه يا رجل اول
تواصل بين حسن نصر الله او بين حزب الله
وبين اهلنا في غزه كان بعد 33 ي من الا
وبتالي وبتالي وبتالي يا سيدي الكريم يا
سيدي الكريم
قاومه حققت العزه للام العربيه وانتم خارج
هذه الا العربيه وار دقيقه خليني اسالك
سؤال بس مشان نجمع الموضوع احد الاخوه من
بوك فريد بن زوغه من الجزائر يقول لك
الغساسنه العرب حلفاء الروم يقاتلون
اخوانهم المناذره حلفاء الفرس وهو الواقع
للاسف دائما يتصارع الروم والفرس في ارض
العرب ويستخدمون حلفائهم العرب لخدمه
مشاريعهم هو يقول في واقع الامر الان نحن
الع لا ناقه لنا العرب لا لنا لا ليس لنا
لا ناقه ولا جمل في الصراع الحاصل الان
على المنطقه بين الاتراك والايرانيين يعني
نحن قسم منا بقاتل مع الاتراك وقسم منا
بقاتل مع
الايرانين كيف ترد على هذا الكلام رح
اجيلك بشكل مباشر كما قلت لك سيدي فلسفه
تركيا في التعامل مع الدول العربيه هما
نقطتين اثنتين النقطه الاولى التعاون
المباشر مع الدول العربيه القائمه ومع
الشعوب شعوب المنطقه تركيا هي من تساهم
اكثر دوله اليوم هي وقطر تساهم في اعاده
اعمار غزه بعد 33 يوم فقط اتصال هاتفي من
جماعه حسن نصر الله بشكل مباشر ل مع
المقاومه هذا هو دعم المقاومه وبالتالي
يعني هذه الاكاذيب
اعتقد انه بعض الثوره السوريه تحديدا التي
هي تعتبر كاشفه لم تعد تنطلي على احد
ايران موقفها اصبح واضحا ايران مستعده
التعامل مع الجميع مع اسرائيل حتى
بالمكشوف ضد الدول العربيه وضد الاستقرار
في هذه المنطقه ايران لو ارادت ان تبني
العراق حقيقه وهي كانت تمكنت من الحكم
وتمكنت من مفاصل الدوله عشر سنوات كنا
وجدنا ما يمكن تسميته بالنموذج الايراني
الحضاري ولكن النموذج الحضاري التركي بشكل
بشكل
واضح اي نعم يا سيدي نموذج حضاري بجراب لس
خلال 100 يوم شفناه بجراب لس والفلسفه
الثانيه والنقطه الثانيه التي تنطلق بها
السياسه التركيه احيي الانسان تحيا الدوله
بمعنى ان الانسان هو الذي يساهم في عمليه
البناء وعمليه النهضه وعمليه الاستقرار
تخريب وقتل يا سيدي قتل اكثر من 4 مليون
انسان قتل سيدي سيبك من العالم العربي
سيبك من العالم العربي خلينا نروح على
نيجيريا نروح على نجيريا م بس خليك دقيقه
بس خيك دقيقه بس دقيقه بس كيف لا لا دقيقه
بس دقيقه خليك شوي بس مشان ماخذ الوقت كله
دكتور هل يمكن ان تدلني على النموذج الرجل
تحدث عن النموذج الحضاري التركي الذي تريد
تركيا ان تقدمه للمنطقه مش يا اخي بس
دقيقه انت انت احكي لي بدك اياه علي هل
يمكن ان تدلني على النموذج الحضاري الذي
قدمته ايران في العراق في سوريا في اليمن
في لبنان في شعبها لشعبها في طهران اللي
عايشين في المقابر اولا ايران انا برجع
باكد انه انا مش ناطق بلسان الحكومه
الايرانيه الموقف بما يقدم مشاريعنا
العربيه بوجه الاستعمار والاستكبار
ايران دوله محاصره منذ 1979 غربيا وعربيا
وشنه الحروب العديده عليها استطاعت من
خلال ذلك ان تبني قواتها الذاتيه وان تبني
مجتمع متكامل له قوميه صح لكن بمنطق
وايديولوجية
ايديولوجي بالاخوان المسلمين يتعدى حدود
الكيانات لانه يؤثر على شرعيه الممالك
الخليجيه الشرعيه العائليه والشرعيه
الدينيه لذلك استعجلت السعوديه ودت هذه
الفكره من اساسها لذلك هنا هناك هون انا
بقول لك الخطر التركي المستقبلي على الامه
العربيه وعلى المنطقه العربيه انطلاقا
اولا من مشاريعها الاستعماريه ثانيا من
فكرتها بالاخوان المسلمين او الفكره
الدينيه الشموليه التي تتعدى كيانات
العربيه لتتحدث عن خلافه اسلاميه كامله
ومعها تلتقى فكره الكيانات الوطنيه للدوله
العربيه هذه هي الخ طط الحقيقيه بس انا
بدي اقول فكره خليني مرقها كمان لا كملي
اياها كملي ايا هذه انه انه تركيا اخطر
على المنطقه ا المروع التركي على المستوى
الديني وعلى المستوى الاستعماري انا انا
بدقول لك شغله روح اعطيك مثل مثل الحسي
مثل حسي اتركني ايران انا ما بدي ادافع عن
ايران وايران دوله مخربه بالعالم الرئيس
بشار
الاسد فتح اقوى علاقات مع تركيا والاقتصاد
السوري عانى عشرات السنوات على حساب
الاقتصاد ونمو الاقتصاد التركي وكانت
علاقات شخصيه ماذا بادره اردوغان غ ان
بتدفق الارهابيين وتدفق المسلحين واقتلاعه
من بغض النظر ماه حق ولا موضوع موضوع ثاني
بس انا عم بقول اذا الرئيس بشار الاسد او
سوريا راحت للحضن الايراني يلعن ابوها ما
بتسوى ما هيك طيب راحت للحضن التركي قوبلت
وجوبه باحتلال وسرقه معاملها و تشريت
سكانها و توليد الارهابيين يا رجل من الذي
من الذي دقيقه دقيقه من الذي من الذي
دقيقه يبدو انت لا علم لك بتاريخ الثوره
السوريه تركي
كانت انظر افضل ايام عاشتها سوريا في
تاريخها عندما عقدت تحالفا اقتصاديا مع
تركيا اجمل اجمل اجمل ايام السوريين دقيقه
خليني نكمل لك اجمل ايام السوريين عاشوها
ايام التحالف مع تركيا ازدهرت سوريا يا
سيدي تركيا
تركيا لم تنقلب انقلبت تركيا انت لا تعرف
يا سيدي حتى العام
2012 و اغلو كان مع بشار الاسد حاولت
المستحيل تركيا الحفاظ على النظام السوري
بالمناسبه للتاريخ اكثر دوله حاولت الحفاظ
على النظام السوري ما حدا بيعرفها تركيا
واسال داوود اغلو حتى عام 2012 لكن تركيا
والعرب والجميع عندما وجدوا شعب عندما
وجدوا نظاما يقتل شعبه تركيا قالت كفى لن
نسير معكم لن نسير
مع مش موضوع التغطيه بس انا بدي اقوله انا
اللي بدي اقوله حتى ارجع للموضوع التركي
انه يشكل خطر على المنطقه العربيه وعلى
الامن القومي العربي اكثر من ايران بكثير
لانه عم شوف انا عم اعطيك نموذج من هذه
التجربه كيف بادرتها تركيا نموذج من
التجربه الفكر الايديولوجي للاخوان
المسلمين الذي يعني تنتهجه اليوم في
المنطقه وكيف يؤثر على المنطقه العربيه و
طيب كيف ترد على بس لا لا لا بسك جاوبني
على هذه النقطه لانه موضوعنا موضوعنا
تركيا وايران كيف ترد على هذا الكلام يقول
لك انتم وزير خارجيتنا قبل كم يوم كما
قلنا اتهم ايران بتشييع المنطقه نعم
واردوغان قال انه ايران تدخل دخلات خطيره
جدا في المنطقه وعليها ان تكف عن ذلك
وبتعرف صار في ازمه بين البلدين على على
مدى الايام الماضيه اه تشييع المنطقه انتم
تتهمون ايران بتشييع المنطقه اه الرجل
يقول لك انتم ايضا متهمون باخون المنطقه
بعثم منه المنطقه الى ما هنالك من هذا
الكلام كيف ترد عليه يا سيدي الدستور
التركي ود وقانون الاحزاب التركيه تمنع
لان يكون لفكر الاخوان في تركيا وجود اصلا
ا وبالتالي ما يدعى ان هناك اخونه اصلا في
نظام الحكم في تركيا هذا امر غير مقبول
دستوريا لا يمكن ان يكون هناك حزب سياسي
مرجعيته مرجعيه دينيه في تركيا نظام الحكم
في تركيا نظام حكم علماني والقانون
الاحزاب والسياسه التركيه تدعو الى ذلك
بشكل واضح وصريح شهدنا خطاب السيد اردوغان
عندما ذهب الى مصر في اول لقاء بينه وبين
الاخوان دعى الى نقطتين اثنتين اولا دعاى
الى حل جما جماعه الاخوان المسلمين بشكل
واضح وصريح داع يا سيدي الى حل جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين وتاسيس احزاب سياسيه على
اسس ديمقراطيه يستطيعون من خلالها التنافس
بشكل ديمقراطي وبش هذا ما قاله اردوغان
هذا ما قاله اردوغان يا
استول عنه اخواني من هون لبعد بكره انا
بحكي لك شو عم يصير او شو صار اصلا وهذا
الكلام مش قبل الانقلاب اللي حصل في مصر
هذا الكلام قبل الانقلاب وقبل ما يستلم
مرسي الحكم اصلا وبالتالي قال لهم اذا
اردتم ان تدخلوا المجال السياسي العام
واردت ان تصيروا ساده فعليكم اولا حل
جماعه الاخوان اللي من خلالها تستطيعون
الدخول في الافق السياسي ثانيا طالبهم
بمبدا الحكم بالعلمانيه وهو امر استفز
الاخوان و سمعنا قيادات جماعه الاخوان في
ذلك الوقت عصام العريان وغيرهم ردوا بشكل
مباشر على السيد اردوغان ان يتدخل في
شؤوننا الداخليه وبالتالي الموقف التركي
حقيقه واضح في هذه الامور لكنكم تريدون
تحميل السياسه التركيه ما لا يحتمل في
قناعتي وبالتالي طيب الت طيب لكن ماذا عن
ايران اذا
انتم انت انتم دقيقه لا لا لا دقيقه لا
تريدون اخوانه المنطقه اما ايران اما
ايران تريد تدمير المنطقه وتشييع المنطقه
تشييع المنطقه كيف يا سيدي تشييع المنطقه
عبر
تاسيس شعارات يا لثارات الحسين اليوم
القتال في سوريا وفي العراق تحت شعار يا
لثارات الحسين
يعني من الذي يثار من الحسين اليوم وضد من
يثار يعني مثل هذه العقيده التاريخيه التي
اسست في القرن الرابع الهجري والتي لا تمت
الى الاسلام بصله لا من قريب ولا من بعيد
ويراد للعالم الاسلامي ان يقاتل تحت
لوائها وتحت شعارها هذا هو الاشكاليه
الكبيره عندما تقوم اليوم ايران بتمويل
عشرات القنوات الفضائيه التي تطعن في
القران الكريم وتسب امهات المؤمنين وصحابه
الرسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم الا تقوم
عمليا بتشييع المنطقه وتشييع حتى العالم
الاسلامي ح الفتنه في ام
رجل دعك حتى من العالم العربي خلينا نطلع
من العالم العربي شوي ونشوف ما فعلته
ايران ما فعلته ايران من تخريب وتدمير
نيجيريا اليوم مهدده بامن القومي من قبل
مليشيات مسلحه ومن خلال التشييع الذي قامت
وتدعمه ايران بشكل مباشر نجيريا ا
الجاليات الاسيه في اوروبا الجاليات
الجاليات التي ناضلت لسنوات طويله من اجل
الحصول على قانون اوروبي يعترف على
اعيادهم الدينيه عيد الفطر وعيد الاضحى
بتيجي الجاليه الايرانيه المدعومه من ملا
ايران ومن الخامنائي وغيرهم ياتون ليقولوا
هذا اليوم ليس عيدا لنا لان هذا اليوم لا
يتطابق مع رؤيتنا في ايران وبالتالي حتى
اعياد المسلمين في اوروبا حرم منها
المسلمون يا سيدي بسبب السياسات الايرانيه
الطائفيه وبالتالي ايران تخريبها تخريبها
ليس فقط على مستوى العالم العربي ليس على
مستوى دعم انقلابات عربيه في البحرين في
سنه 81 دعم الانقلاب في عام 2014 في اليمن
دعم اغتيال محاوله امير الكويت دعم
خطف اليرتين كويتيين بشكل مباشر وتورط حزب
الله صح يعني في هذا الامر دعم الهجمات
الارهابيه في كل من السعوديه والكويت
والبحرين ولبنان والعراق يعني ايران
متورطه يا سيدي في الاعتداء على حجاج بيت
الله الحرام على سنوات متعدده كلنا شهدنا
هذا الامر ايران الذي تزرع الاسلحه
والمتفجرات والخلايا النائبه في عدد من
الدول العربيه وتقوم بتسليح جماعات تحت
مسمى الشيعه العرب ايران يا سيدي ايران يا
سيدي التي دعمت الاحتلال التي دعمت
الاحتلال الامريكي في العراق وافغانستان
ايران التي اوت قيادات تنظيم القاعده كسيف
العدل الذي تواصل مع الخلايا قبل
ق سيدي ايران هي التي تقوم بمسانده حتى
داعش ان تقوم بالتخريب في كل من سوريا
والعراق هناك يعني المشروع الايراني اعتقد
انه مشروع اوضح من الش ماشي بس خلص انا
بدي اسالك بس سؤال انت اتهمت تركيا اه
بمحاوله تعميم النموذج الاخواني انت قلت
ايران تش الكيانات التطيب بس بدي اسالك
سؤال انا كيف اصدق هذه التهمه التي توجهها
لتركيا بانها تريد ان تفرض النموذج
الاخواني على العالم العربي وانه العرب
وخاصه الخليجيين خافوا من الاخوان وقضوا
عليهم طيب انا كيف بدي اصدق هذا الكلام
اذا كانت افضل العلاقات الان اذا افضل
العلاقات الان بين دول الخليج وتركيا لا
حتى التحالف لا حبيبي التحالف التركي السع
هي
الا دقيقه دقيقه التحالف الان هناك هناك
تحالف تركي سعودي متصاعد تحالف قطري تحالف
قطري حتى الامارات بس دقيقه بس دقيقه حتى
الامارات انا بسال لا سؤالي سؤالي سؤ
سؤالي انه انا ما بصدق كلامك اخوي يعني
كيف خايفين من الاخ يعمل مع تح ليبيا شو
صار فيها بالدعم التركي شو صار فيها ومصر
كانت على الطريق ما هيك ط وغيرها من
تدخلات في المنطقه بما يؤسس لحاله اخوانيه
في المنطقه تضع يدها تركيا على المستوى
الاستراتيجي وعلى قراراتها بشكل احتلال او
شبه احتلال بس انا اللي بدي اقوله انت
فعلا لطلي نظري استذ غول فعلا انا هلا بدي
اغير من موقفي يعني تجا اذا ايران قادره
تعبس بالمنطقه وبعالم بامريكا وتدخل الى
اللوبي قادره انها تشيع ا المنطقه كلها
وصولا لنيجيريا وقادره انها تفرض على
المسلمين في اوروبا نظرتها الايديولوجيه
الاسلاميه الشيعيه اللي بدك وقدره انه كل
هذا المسرح السياسي في المنطقه انا فعلا
بدي اغير نظر دعم اسرائيلي لحظه لحظه
وقادره انه تنتج داعش وتنتج القاعده وتنتج
وتنتج وتنتج ما هيك طيب مش قادره د سبر
سبر ومش قادره تشيع 4 ملايين سنه في عندها
بقلب الدوله الايرانيه والله شي فظيع يعني
انا يعني سؤال بتشيع اللي عند طيب لا ما
بتشيع يب ه الحكي طيب بس دقيقه بس خليني
اسالك خليني اسالك على موضوع التشيع دقيقه
بس دكتور دكتور دكتور انا من سوريا انا من
سوريا ها انا من سوريا قبل الثوره بسنتين
كنت في سوريا وكنت ابحث عن اسمنت ابحث عن
اسمنت في سوريا اه فذهبت الى وزير لا اريد
ان اذكر اسمه الان قلت له يا اخي معقول ما
في اسمنت في سوريا قال لي هناك اسمنت كثير
في سوريا لدينا كثير من الاسمنت لكن يا
فيصل على جنب قال ايه قبل الحرب قبل الحرب
قال لي لكن يا فيصل الاسمنت معظم الاسمنت
في سوريا يذهب لبناء الحسينيات الايرانيه
في سوريا هذا كلام وزير سوري قبل الحرب
قبل الثوره السوريه هذه هذه نقطه طيب بدي
اسالك سؤال من الذي يقوم بعمليه
التهجير وتشييع المناطق في سوريا عندما
خرج سكان داريا سكان داريا اول يوم خرج
منها سكان داريا في محيط دمشق في اليوم
التالي اتت ايران بالشيعه العراقيين
والشيعه الافغان والشيعه الكذا واصبحت
داريه بين ليله وضحاها شيعيه مع انها
مدينه سنيه من
9823 ترليون سنه لا لا لا دقيقه لا لا بس
بدي اسالك بدي اسالك انا بدي اسالك في في
كل المناطق التي هجر اهلها من الذي كان
يشرف على عمليه
خل في القصير في وادي برده في مضايا في
الزبداني في داريا في راحوا حتى على
السويده عند دروس الان عم يحاولوا يشيع
الوس وعندك غسان قرضاب وعندك كميل نصر
وعندك شو اسمه تبع المخابرات العسكريه
كلياتهم عم شيعوا والفلوس تدفع بالملايين
في سوريا لتشييع
المنطقه بدي اسالك بس بس دقيقه بس دقيقه
لا لا بس النقطه هذه بس النقطه هذه بس
النقطه هذه بتيجي بتق لي انه تركيا يا
سيدي اذا ك ترك ايران تريد تشيع المنطقه
وسوريا مثالا حزام دمشق الان هو نسخه طبق
الاصل عن حزام بغداد بغداد كان حزام كله
سنه تحول الى شيعه الان حزام دمشق كان كله
سنه يتحول الى شيعه باشراف ايراني بتيجي
بتقول لي اخوان مسلمين واخوان اخوان ايه
ونيله ايه يا رجل كيف ترد طيب انا رح اقول
لك انت اول شيء بدك تتحدث عن سوريا نتحدث
بعطيك امثله كثيره انا امثله ك من هذه
اعطيناك نحن اكثر من امثله وما ما اخذت
فيه يعني ما ما ما استشهدت فيهم طيب لو
كان هيك انه هذه الشيعيه المستحدثه وكذا
مثل ما انت عم بتصورها انه موجوده بسوريا
طيب ليش ما هو العراق اقرب بالحوز واقرب
بالمقامات الدينيه الشيعيه طيب لذلك هناك
في خلاف شيعي داخل العراق بالنسبه لايران
وبالنسبه للنظره الى ايران يعني معناته ما
في تشيع هك بالمنطقه مثل ما عم تقولوا حطت
ايدها على العراق يعني هذا التباين في
المواقف السياسيه بين القوى السياسيه
الشيعيه والسنيه اصلا بالنسبه لايران يعني
معناته انه هناك ما في حالات تشو يعني
هناك قوى سياس شيعيه على خصومه مع ايران
موقف
ايران يعني فاذا انه ما في هذا الواقع
اللي انت عم تقوله هي سوريا العراق اقرب
بكثير منيران بالنسبه للمقاومات
ونسه الجزء يعني انا انا بدي اتحدث يعني
انتم عم تحكوا بواقع على المستوى المذهبي
والتشييع طيب اردوغان تحدث خلال لاث سنوات
بالكثير عن القوميات
والاثنيات الان وال الايزيديات وغير ذلك
باكثر من من موقع والحاله السنيه انا اللي
بدي روح للموضوع الاعم والاهم ايران تريد
ان تلعب دور في واقع عربي يريد استهدافها
لذلك لا تريد كسر هذه السلسله التي يمكن
ان تقوي عضدها وهي العراق والمقاومه في
لبنان ومنها سوريا بطبيعه الحال لذلك هي
لا طيب قابلوا بامر سني ليش العرب ما
قابلوه بامر سني واحتضنوا كل الواقع العرب
لا تركيا خارج المنظومه نعتبر انه هي خارج
المنظومه ماه عليها وهي وهي مكتفه وهي
مكتفه وبتجنن و ما ل ما لها شيء ليش قابل
تفضل قله بحوار بامر سني كبير يحتضن
القضيه الفلسطينيه وقضايا العرب كلها
وبالتالي وبالتالي حكما هذا الفراغ الذي
تملاه بلدان عربيه وازنه قويه حكما سيكون
هناك انتفاء للدوره التركي وللدور الب على
سؤاله انه ايران لم تجب على سؤاله انا
يعني سال سؤال مهم سؤال الله بعين علينا ا
سؤال كيف تنظر ايران للمنطقه العربيه وكيف
تنظر تركيا تركيا حتى الان تتحدث عندما
تذكر دمشق عندما تذكر سوريا ت تسميها بشو
شام شريف اما ايران فلا فليس لها في
منطقتنا العربيه الا ثارات الحسين لا تنظر
الينا الا ك شو اسمه احفاد يزيد ومعاويه
وما بعرف شو وتريد وتريد ان تثار منا
وتثار مما فعله سيدنا عمر بها قبل قبل
مئات السنين السؤال المطروح هذه نظره
تركيا شاام شريف مقابل العداء ليزيد
ومعاويه جاوبني على النقطه هذه هو قك يا
دكتور فيصل انا بالحديث وخليني انا اكون
واضح يعني انا بالحديث على المستوى
المذهبي شام شريف وار
الحسين مش انه هو تهرب بس هذا يعني حديث
مش
لب قضيه لا الصراع الاساسي ما في صراع سني
شيعي في المنطقه هناك صراع سياسي مع قو
يه على راسها اسرائيل وقوى متواطئه
وتريد ان تركب المو الاطلسيه لاحتلال
منطقتنا هذه هي المنطقه وهذا هو واقع
الصراع مشراع مذهبي الصراع المذهبي لو كان
موجود ما كان تحالفات بين تركيا وبين
ايران قديما وحتى عام يا اخي خلال الازمه
السوريه خلال الازمه السوريه دكتور فيصل
خلال الازمه السوريه الم تصل المبادلات
التجاريه ما بين تركيا وايران الى 30
مليار دولار ب ما كانت شيعيه ليش هلا صارت
شيعيه كيف الك جميل ط كيف ت بس دقيقه انت
قلت نقطه اليس هناك الكثير من المبالغه في
في هذا الكلام الوقت يداهمنا خلينا نخلص
انت تقول قبل قليل قلت حتى العلويون في
سوريا لو خيروا بين الذهاب الى ايران او
تركيا ذهبوا الى تركيا مع انها مع انهم
يعتبرونها عدوتهم كيف يعني كيف هذا الكلام
تركيا يا سيدي تنفتح للجميع اليوم لنفترض
حتى صار لو حصل بين المعارضه وبين النظام
حسم عسكري شكله الانفتاح ماشي هذا الحسم
العسكري وين رح يروحوا العلويين يروحوا
على ايران يعني الذي لم تستقبل ولا 100
لاجئ سوري ولا حيروح على موسكو حجوا على
تركيا بطبيعه الحال لانه هذا النسيج
الاجتماعي وهذا هو المكان الذي حجد انفسهم
الملاذ الامن الملاذ الامن وتركيا ستقدم
بواجبها تجاههم كل الضيافه كما فعلت تجاه
اكراد العراق في التسعينات عندما استقبلت
اكثر من 00 ال عراق بس خليك خليك شوي خليك
نقطه هون بس مشان ما تروح النقطه لانه
الوقت يداهمنا بس بدي اسالك سؤال دكتور هل
تستط ت ان تقول لي كم لاجئ سوري وعراقي
استقبلت تركيا وكم لاجئ سوري وعراقي ويمني
استقبلت ايران لا لا دقيقه جاوبني هل
استقبلت ايران هل استقبلت ايران لاجئ سوري
واحد هي استقبلتهم وبنت مخيماتهم قبل
الحور
هنا دقيقه هناك ثلاثه ملايين لاجئ سوري في
تركيا
يعيشون يا اخي مش مختلف معك بس دقيقه بس
دقيقه هناك ثلاثه ملايين لاجئ سوري يعيشون
معززين مكرمين مكرمين مكرمين في تركيا بس
انا بدي تحدا كم لاج يا اخي خليني اكمل لك
السؤال وخذ يا دكتور كم لاجئ سوري مش هي
حليفه المقاومه والممانعه مش هي رئيس
حليفه النظام السوري هل استقبلت ايران
لاجئ سوري واحد هل اعطت فيزا واحده لسوري
بس دقيقه حتى العلويين حتى العلويين
العلويون السوريون الان عن عندما جاء
الروس الى سوريا تنفسوا السعداء قال الحمد
لله خلصتو من ايران بدي اسالك الشيعه في
الكويت عندما غزى صدام حسين الكويت شيعه
العراق عفوا شيعه الكويت هل ذهبوا الى
ايران ذهبوا الى السعوديه ذهبوا الى
السعوديه خ خليني اجبك اولا بنت تركيا
المخيمات قبل حصول الازمه السوريه هذا
اولا ثانيا بسبب القرب الجغرافي من
الطبيعي انه السكان يتوافد على الحدود مثل
ما توافدوا على لبنان يعني 3 ملايين
بالنسبه لتركيا ولا شيء قياسا بلبنان بلد
صغير 7 ملون لب لب
كثيرا المقاومه جزء اساسي بالنسبه لايران
يمكن الواقع الجغرافي او المنطقه
الجغرافيه او التباعد الجغرافي يمنع هذا
الموضوع ما بدي انا كمان اكون يعني محامي
اكثر يعني بهذا الموضوع لكن انا بدي اقول
بس شغله خل بس مشان مرقه يا سيدي انت تتهم
تركيا بابتلاع سوريا وكذا يا سيدي تركيا
لديها 900 كيل متر حدود مع سوريا وين حدود
ايران عن سوريا ليش جاي عندي ايران على
حلب ويجي يقول لي نائب رئيس الحرس ال ووري
الحرس الثوري يقول حلب خط الدفاع الاول عن
الثوره الايرانيه يا ابن الف شو دخلك انت
بشو
اسمه يا دكتور فيصل هذا جزء من تحالف
استراتيجي بس انا اللي بدي اقوله اذا انت
عم تتحدث عن السياسه عن السياسه التركيه
وسياسه اردوغان انا معك خل نقفل بس بنص
دقيقه بنص دقيقه وصك بدكون ونتحدث عن
تغيير الانظمه الاستبداديه ان كانت في
سوريا وان كانت في العراق وان كانت مطرح
ما بدك انا معك ما هيك طيب اردوغان ارتكب
باسبوع
واحد اكبر استبداد في التاريخ الانساني
يوم الانقلاب ما حدا تحدث عنه انا شوف
العالم اليوم الموجوده بالسجون والاستبداد
شوف التسلط واتخاذ القرارات والتفرد
بالقرارات المستقبل صير بالاستفتاء لحدث
عنه من ي الاستفتاء حتى اليوم لم يقتل
شخصا واحدا حتى ممن تورطوا حتى ممن تورطوا
باغتياله وحده وحدتين كوماندوز خاصه نزلوا
بالهليكوبتر عشان يقتلوه
واقت الاتراك من العرب و قتل الايرانيون
يا سيدي رغم الاشتباك اللي حصل بين حرس
الرئيس وقتل ثلاثه هؤلاء معتقلون وسيحاكم
محاكمه عادله قسين لو حصل اخلاف في
سوريا حتى في ايران يا
رجلش رجل لا تقارن تركيا تقدم نموذج
ديمقراطي تقد ق تقم للمحاكمات
حاله المعارضه كلها معروفه كلها في الخارج
ومن كان في الداخل
هو قصدك كم معارض ايراني موجود في الداخل
وكم معارض تركي مزبوط بس انا بدي بدي اضيف
اكثر من حمى اردوغان يوم انقلابه اليست
ايران وروسيا لا طبعا مين ل كان كف حموا
يعني ما معنى ما معنى الحمايه اصال اتفي
هو الذي يعني بمعنى
الحما
هو الذي غير المعادله يا سيدي لا دوله
خارجيه ولا ولا قوه داخليه الشعب هو الذي
استطاع ان
ي هناك
[تصفيق]
قضم ان يقرا المناهج الايرانيه الدراسيه
التي حتى موجود دراسات عنها احد الباحثين
الدكاتره الاردنيين عمل دراسه عن صوره
العرب في المناهج الدراسيه الايرانيه انا
اتمنى منك حقيقه يا دكتور يا عروبي ان
تقرا صوره العرب في المناهج الدراسيه
الايرانيه وكم يحتقرون هؤلاء العرب كيف
اتحدث
بعنصريه هذه العنصريه
العثمانيه اتمنى حقيقه تعرف من تدافع عنه
هذه النقطه الاولى كنت اتمنى من اسمع كلمه
عن الاحواز العربيه الاحواز العربيه التي
تبلغ مساح الغرايه
350 مربع وهي محتله من ايران في الوقت
الرا كنت اتمنى ان اسمع منك عن الجزر
الام مساحه
الاهواز مع
اسرام اردغان افضل مننه
خام اردوغان افضل من جنه خامنائي هذا ما
يقوله الجمهور العربي اليوم ي الجور
العربي هو الرفعه والكرامه العربيه في وجه
العدو الاسرائيلي الذي
دعمت بعد يا زلمه في عدو شو اسمه يا رجل
عدو اسرائيلي الله يسامحكم طيب مش مشكله
ولا همك لم يبقى لنا لنشكر ضيفين الدكتور
رائد المصري والسيد محمد زاهد جول نلتقي
مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى ذلك الحين هاه
فيصل قاسم يحييكم من
الدوحه
[موسيقى]
c